[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Welcome to the
quick start tutorial
for the BigQuery web UI.
Head over to the
navigation menu and find
BigQuery listed under Big Data.
BigQuery provides some public
data sets that we can access.
For the first part
of this quick start,
we'll use a data set of
USA names between the years
1910 and 2013.
Here is a query editor.
Let's find out what the most
common names are in our data
set.
On the lower right side,
there's a green check mark icon.
When we click it, it
runs a query validator
that will tell us
if our query is
valid without having to run it.
If our query is invalid, it
will tell us the error so
that we can go back
and correct it.
Otherwise, we're good to go.
Click Run to run our query.
The results will appear below.
We can view the query results
as a table or in JSON format.
We also have the option
to save the results.
How about if we want
to load our own data?
To check this out,
we'll use a text file
that contains the most common
US baby names of the year 2014.
This is what the
file looks like--
a Comma-Separated Value file,
CSV, with three columns.
To load this test
data into BigQuery,
let's create a data set.
In the navigation panel,
in the Resources section,
click your project name.
Then, over on the right,
in the details panel,
click Create Dataset.
For data set ID,
let's enter babynames.
For data location,
we'll put United States.
We can leave all other fields
with their default values,
and click Create Dataset.
We've got a data set.
Now we can load the
data into a new table.
Back over in the
Resources section,
we'll see our babynames
data set under our project.
Click it.
In the details panel,
click Create Table.
Let's change the source
from Empty Table to Upload.
Click Browse, and find the
CSV file with our data in it.
We also want to make sure
that we select the right file
format, CSV.
We'll give our table a name,
names_2014, and toggle Edit
As Text to define a schema--
name, string, gender,
string, and count, integer.
Click Create Table.
Now that we've loaded
data into a table,
we should be able to query it.
Click Compose New Query.
Let's find out the top five
male names in our table.
Click Run, and we'll
get the results here
below the query window.
And voila, that's a quick
start on BigQuery's web UI.
[MUSIC PLAYING]